the stories are as entertaining and
powerful as any found in films that
feature flesh-and-blood actors and their
characters are just as funny complex and
inspiring and flesh-and-blood actors are
migrant workers we travel all over the
world
we build families we construct stories
we build life that cannot be divided as
a Mexican as a Latin American as a
migrant worker as a human being I'm
against any form of wall that wants to
separate us
and these are the nominees for Best
Animated Feature Film Kubo and the two
strings Travis Knight and REM sadness
Moana John Musker
Ron Clements and oz not sure my life at
the zucchini cloud badass and Max called
the red turtle
Michael booze of the beat and Toshio
Suzuki Zootopia Byron Howard rich Moore
and Clark Spencer and the Oscar goes to
utopia
this is the first Oscar for a Byron
Howard rich more and flex sensor Byron
Howard is previously nominated for the
animated feature film volt and rich
Morris previously nominated for record
Rock
[Music]
Wow thank you guys so much thank you
Academy this is an incredible incredible
honor about five years ago almost six
now oh my god we got this crazy idea to
talk about humanity with talking animals
in the hopes that when the film came out
it would make the world just a slightly
better place and we are so grateful to
the audience's all over the world who
embraced this film with this story of
Tolerance being more powerful than fear
of the other we want to thank Bob Iger
Alan horn Alan Bergman John Lasseter Ed
Catmull and Andrew Milstein for creating
an amazing studio for us to work at and
every artist technician and manager at
Disney Animation who poured your heart
and soul into this film this award
belongs to you
thank you oh thank you very much and we
wanted to all to say it looks like you
thanks Shepherd my husband steadiest us
and my parents
[Music]